hello everyone um Carlos
shider and I am going to tell
[Music]
you about next Generation PDFs with
cardo and typist and I half the time I
talked about my let's make that a little
smaller so it's not stomping over there
uh I gave the title of my talk as never
again in alterar mode and uh if you know
what alterar mode is you know uh what
the St is about if not let me tell you
so you're writing quto you've heard this
week it's excellent we love it I'm a
fulltime developer on quto I'm biased
but I really think it's quite good and
we try really hard to make it even
better so if it's not good for me for
you we want to hear about it so you
write your report it's excellent you're
so ready to share it with the the world
and you need to mail it to someone so it
needs to be a PDF so you write your file
and you go and hit render or you call
quarto render and we'll go yes we'll
render it for you it's PDF we'll use
latch which is the way to create
beautiful PDF
files and then it says it's updating its
its Tech Live manager but you didn't ask
to update it it's telling you it's ex I
didn't I don't want any new packages I
want my my report
and then it just says it failed and the
reason it failed is it's not an alterar
mode and if you've ever used quarto and
PDF unfortunately I think you've seen
this before because it comes up all the
time and it's just a horrible error
message um so you look at it it's like
what do I do now okay it's not an outer
part mode okay let's go look at this
it's like okay see the latch manual or
the latch companion for explanation or
press AG for help turns out you get that
even not in an interactive promp you
can't press h it's just on a file
somewhere and then it says okay let's go
look at the index. log for more
information because it's an error great
they told me about the error let's go
look at it that's
50,000 characters of of error messages
but okay maybe maybe it's there and so
you go look at the file and you're just
like okay okay okay like no no I'm I'm
no I'm I'm going back to bed I'll try
this tomorrow I'm I'm this is not going
to be this is not going to be good and
this happens all the time uh this is a
true story I didn't know whether I
wanted to give this this talk with this
title because I thought it doesn't come
up at often it recently has came up
three separate times for me recently
means since Saturday since since since
getting here at the conference where I'm
not developing quto three separate times
I ran into this so um no never again in
outer part mode let's not do that by the
way I used lch for 20 years used to be
an academic before I joined I counted I
wrote more than a hundred P papers in
latch and I this trips me up
still I hope we don't have to sort of
inflict on you this pain anymore I want
I want us to solve this problem so bad
latak is beautiful it was a
groundbreaking system it is still the
way to generate the most beautiful PDF
documents you can but I think there's an
alternative now and this is what I want
to tell you about um so um if you're
ready for coffee there's a fantastic
talk coming up after mine but um if you
want to sort of go back and then come
back for the next talk here's what I'm
going to tell you about types is a new
system that quto uses that lets you
do PDF files I really hope it displaces
latch it's you're going to see why it's
awesome you can download it today it's
available in 1.4 pre-releases but we're
still going to support latch forever so
if you must use latch don't despair
we're not throwing it away we're keeping
it
here it's a little bit of extra work
because it's so new but I'll show you
where the sharp edges are
so what's types the first thing is it's
a weird way to pronounce it but it's on
their website I used to say typist maybe
we can convince them to change but it's
types it is a new system for making PDF
documents and um if you go to their
website they say that it's for Rocket
scientists but it's for the rest of us
too which is great and what they say is
it views your changes instantly it
provides clear and understandable error
messages it has a consistent styling
system and it uses familiar programming
constructs I want to tell you about all
of that because that's all true and it's
really great so I hope we can convince
you to do that so quto meet types what
um what do you have to do to get types
working hopefully you don't have to do
anything if this is your quarto document
with your yo front matter your title
your author and your format
it might just be a matter of switching
from format PDF to format types if
you're okay with a sort of standard
formatted document this works today and
you're going to get a PDF document the
advantage of that is you do not need to
sty tiny Tech you're it is bundled with
quto and it is much faster than lat Tech
so hopefully you might not have to do
anything but I'll show you what else you
get if you actually
want to go to the next step so I'm going
to give you four quick demos today I'm
going to show you how to make academic
posters with quto I don't know if Lisa
is in the audience uh I got a to tell
you how easy this is um I had three tiny
demos to show you today and then Lisa
told me that we really need academic
posters in quto and we knew there was a
template for typist and so I was like I
think we can do this and and we set it
up last night in the hotel before the
talk today you can go check my GitHub
reposit for the stock and you will see
that that's I'm going to show you how
the errors are
nice I'm going to show you this really
fantastic feature about how it handles
fonts and I'm going to show you a really
cool completely new design for documents
that just really showcases the power of
types so let's start with
posters
and here
so here is
a demo
so I'm using vs code which apparently
according to Nick makes me a maniac of
some kind I apologize um I'm used to it
this is a quto document it's just marked
down if you have format equals HTML and
you ask it to render we'll fire up a
preview we will run it and you'll get a
preview just like uh you would for any
website right so you get that it's not
an academic poster but it's your content
there's some figures there there's lists
tables equations images and so on and so
forth so like's say that you needed to
do an academic poster as of last
night if you
switch your format from there to types
do you see that you have to do things a
little bit different we're going to fix
this in about 24 more hours I just
didn't have time to do that we'll be
using all of the metadata from quto
we're not right now so it's not
perfect let's try again we tell it
please preview and we're going to make a
You
poster and now you got a poster
okay so that's kind of cool
um I wasn't sure whether or not people
were going to use it and then I this
morning someone pinged me on Mastadon
saying hey I made a CR poster with this
it just worked so there's at least one
person that made it work so uh trust me
this is this is easy um you can see the
formatting is a little bit different
right the tables are rendered a little
bit differently the code blocks are
rendered not quite the same but they're
pretty close and we're working to make
it as close as possible you get
equations you get lists you get other
kinds of things that I hope to show you
so for example here is a block of text
that has a different color behind it so
this is my first opportunity to show you
a little bit about
how types actually looks like in code
because I want to show you that it's
actually really kind of simple so here's
a raw code block for types so in in quto
if you want to do something that's
format specific you use these raw blocks
to get the code to do what you want and
so if you want a block that the
background is this light gray that is
inside eight points from the margin and
it has a radius of four you start a
block this is the way that you call a
command from
ppes you put your markdown code inside
including markdown things like lists and
then you just close your block here
right so there's an even easier way to
do this with using divs from pendock but
I just wanted to show you sort of what
this looks like if you were to sort of
have to do the fancy sort of uh pure
type thing I don't know if you've ever
had to do this in latek I promise you
this one is so much cleaner and easier
to work than than that and it will give
you give you a reason to do that let's
say that if you happened to type that
instead of RGB because you thought that
that's what how colors worked
right well they don't work exactly like
that but this gives me a chance to show
you error
messages okay so I'm running the dev
version of quto so I want to know
exactly where the error came you won't
see this you are going to see this part
right
here where it's saying compiler poster
error I expected a caller or none but I
found a string right
here compared that too not in alter par
mode it's like what error did I make
that it says not in alterar mode it's
got nothing to do with my code when
typist makes an error it tells you what
the error is and say it was expecting a
caller and you gave it a string and it
points you exactly in the source where
that is and it does that very
consistently and it's some of the best
error messages that I've ever seen and I
spent six months working in quartal
error messages so I care about them
these folks have done a fantastic job of
their own so I'm happy to show you that
we can actually then guide you to do the
right thing so error messages and types
are just really
nice let me tell you about fonts so if
you've ever used PDF lch from way back
then font support Is Not Great there's
no unic code support it's very hard to
figure out if your code is going to
render the way that you want it's just
generally a
mess Lu attack and Zatch do a little bit
better but still the system itself
doesn't know a lot about fonts and so
it's hard for it to reason about what's
possible so let me start with a very
basic demo here so we again are going to
show this and I'm going to tell
you here is font support right so again
I'm starting with a raw block here that
says set the text to be of a particular
font but notice I'm using two fonts and
not one the other thing I'm doing is I'm
putting a fenced div around that
statement and the reason I'm doing that
is to show you that naturally type it
will keep its state to the blocks around
it so this just happens by natural sort
of way in which types work which is not
how lch work and you have to remember
does this one work in the current
environment does this work set for the
entire document am I going to get it
wrong in types everything is scoped if
you want to keep your changes to
something you just put a block around it
and everything just
works so here is my text let's render it
just going to do the same thing as
before
and now what's neat about this one
is if you like
Avatar you get your Papyrus font but you
didn't get the Papyrus font for the
second
one because the Papyrus font does not
have the Arabic glyphs for that so it
detects it and it says hey I cannot
possibly render for that one let me try
the next font you gave me which is the
Arabic Fone for uh it's the Noto Arabic
Fone from Google and it renders it and
not only does it render it I
unfortunately do not know how to read
Arabic but ligatures in Arabic texts are
extremely important because they
actually change the meaning of the word
so they're not very readable and so in
Old PDF this is very hard to do in types
you just get that for free and these are
rendered properly if the font supports
it so this is something that's kind of
impossible to do in lat Tech you just
get it for free in types it's really
nice um so last Quick
demo for something completely different
but if you are running a small
Department like an institution you want
to have a newsletter you're College
somewhere this is a newsletter I just
want to show you how it's possible to do
something that looks completely
different that almost looks like it was
typ set with something like illustrator
or something of that sort it's just
another
format and this is what it looks like
there we go so you have two columns you
can put sort of code on one column or
code on the other you have links and so
on and you still have your code so you
can line things just like you would in
your sort of R markdown quarto inline
code they're just there you can do sort
of fancy treatments for these and cross
references and they all work and the
content for this
looks like your markdown and it's
semantic if you want to say put
something on the sidebar that's an
article you just make a fence div that
says article and then the template is
going to put
there the reason I'm sharing with this
with you is I want to show you something
real quick that might have escaped
notice just to show you how incredible
types is as understanding Graphics look
at this part right here where it says
award-winning science and pay attention
to this line
here looks very innocuous right it's
just a line there it's a little sus
right like it knows how to end exactly
at the right spot is that a coincidence
what's going on there right you know you
know if you're in a different place
maybe you don't do award-winning science
you do okay science it's okay it's
fine but if you want to has
newsletter we got you and now pay
attention to
this look at where the line
went so types knows how to reason about
font sizes right on the language so if
you want to do things like I want to
take this thing and I want to stretch it
so that it fits exactly at the right
spot or if this test text is too big I
want it to render with a different font
you can all do this from a real
programming language with scope with
variables with error messages
so if you're a template user this is so
much better than latch I cannot tell you
if you've written any latch template
you're like thinking this is impossibly
good I promise it's very very easy and I
will show you how easy it
is where is the template for the
Department use it'ss right there and
this just looks like code it's
incredible so let's close the other ones
I'm almost done with my talk I
promise the way this works is literally
you just ask for the size of the content
and then you
use you align it
to whatever is left you measure the
image you find the correct line width
and then you subtract it from the other
one so right in your code you just
literally say how big was this text that
I was going to render it's this much
make the line that's all that one it's a
real programming language operating on
text with full right to left support
ligature support computation all of that
great error messages very easy to write
this is you can you can kind of see
what's doing it's not complicated you
want to do two columns here's the First
Column here's the other column is right
there it's actually incredibly clean and
well-designed
so I hope this gets you excited to
actually put sort of you know try it out
it's actually much better than I thought
I was okay that's not a
great what happened there hello
this is what happens with life demos I
apologize there we go
somehow we were here but I'm done with
my talk so here's sharp address before
we're
done I rich just presented and rich is
the table Master of the Universe if you
don't know like GT is just
mind-blowingly good and it pains me to
tell you that we don't get GT support in
types right now but we're going to work
on it it's possible it's just not there
yet so some features are not there we we
have call outs in quto they don't quite
work they sort of render but they're
kind of not great so this came out so
types has existed for about a year and a
half so it's very new there's a lot of
support out there already but it's a
little early so you're probably going to
have to do
something but we want to help you so if
this excites you as sort of an
alternative for doing PDFs that is not
lch has better messages it's kind of
great please give it a try and let us
know what you find so that's it if you
want to find more we have documentation
links to this slide and the
talks happy to take
[Applause]
questions thank you there are a couple
of
questions uh first one is the obvious
question so how about equations is it
decent enough to replace lch so there's
a demo of equations uh right on the
poster so you can see it's very good but
it's not as good as latek is right now
so if you uh you might have to do a
little bit of digging but extending it's
quite simple and they're getting better
sort of every day they do a new release
every two three weeks and they all
improve equations so it will be there in
probably three months or so I'd say it's
90% there but it's not
100% second question will short codes
work with types yes um if your short Cod
emits just regular markdown which most
do they will work with types it's just
another quto feature that just should
work well together yes um we should have
tested the icons rich I didn't realize
it but uh we'll make sure it works by
tonight
okay uh next question what would it take
to develop the document in types and
then convert it to latch to submit it to
a journal for example um what I would
recommend you do is uh so if you go on
my uh on the repository that I had there
um linked uh I have a document that was
a paper I published as an academic that
I converted it to qmd and I have it sort
of compiling from quto to latch and to
types and that's the easiest way to do
it but if you are having a hard time you
can try to use something like Melissa
suggested earlier which is pendock Will
parse from the output back into the
input if you want to try that so I
haven't tested it for types but that's
sort of something you can try to do so
you take the types output convert it to
latch and then you go I think you should
just use quto markdown for it and Target
both of those because that's nice but
there might be a way to do the fancy way
out okay last question does types
support other output formats than PDF
not yet um they said that they're going
to support HTML but it's not out yet so
right now they're used as a PDF engine
in the same way that we use latch only
as a PDF engine even though you can get
more things out of latch as
well thank you thank
you